Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking it.
I'm a cybernetic organism
living tissue over
this episode is brought to you
by four sigmatic.
I reached out to these
Finnish entrepreneurs after
a very talented acrobat,
introduced me to one of their products,
which blew my mind and the best
way possible it is mushroom coffee.
What on earth is this? Well,
it includes Chaga mushroom,
very powerful antioxidant,
considered a super food.
I was introduced to
Chaga by Laird Hamilton,
the King of Big Wave
Surfing of all things,
and it includes another mushroom that
is considered a no tropic, a smart drug,
and this is lion's mane in the entire
packet. You just add it to hot water.
It tastes like coffee.
There is only 40 milligrams of caffeine,
so less than half what you
would find in a cup of coffee.
So I do not get any jitters.
I do not get any acid reflux or any type
of stomach burn and it put me on fire
for an entire day and I
only had half of the packet.
So this stuff is really amazing.
People are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement. Right now.
This is the answer, so it is legal.
It will not give you visuals.
That's something else and you can try it
right now by going to foursigmatic.com
forward slash Tim that is
for Sig Madec, s I, g m,
a t I c foursigmatic.com forward slash
Tim and use the Code Tim to get 20% off
your first order.
If you are in the experimental mindset,
I do not think you'll be disappointed.
foursigmatic.com forward slash
Tim
this episode is brought to
you by Wealthfront and this
is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive
in a good way, set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists
from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last
two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars
under management. In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions
of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why? Why is
it so popular? Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them.
And this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams, et cetera. And
I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com
forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz,
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they'd put you in.
And if you just want to take their advice,
run with it, do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it.
And here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be on a regular
basis but normally aren't.
Great investing is a marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with.
Like automatic tax loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods
of time. Wealthfront, as I mentioned,
since it's using software
instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low
costs that were previously completely
impossible.
Right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free.
If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim that
is less than $5 a month to invest a
$30,000 account for instance.
Now, normally when I have
a sponsor on this show,
it's because I use them and
recommend them. In this case
it's a little different.
I don't use wealth front yet because
I'm not allowed to. Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of sec regulations,
companies that invest your money are
not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user end
have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront
that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money, at least for me,
uh, in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope
to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation
as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free
if you decide to open an account.
But just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes, fill out their
questionnaire@wealthfront.com
forward slash. Tim,
it's fast, it's free. There's
no downside that I can think of.
Little Boys and girls,
one bets and squirrels.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world
class performers, tease out the habits,
routines, favorite books, etc.
That you can use in your own life.
And I'm speaking in hushed tones
cause I'm in the airport in,
I don't like to yell and scream like a
lunatic one in the airport lest I get a
boot on my head.
So the guest Mike Birbiglia,
I've wanted to interview Mike for years.
You can find them on Twitter
at [inaudible] Bir vigs.
He is one of the best known and
busiest working comedians in the world,
both behind and in front of the camera.
His standup blends a lot of elements,
different elements, theater,
film, storytelling and comedy.
This is of interest to me because
he's been very deliberate in studying
different crafts and tying them together
and this is reflected in his string of
successes which include sold out
tours as a solar theater act.
He just did a hundred
cities not too long ago,
New York Times bestselling books
off Broadway shows, feature film TV,
and much more in the last few years
has work has started to appear on this
American life,
which is an incredible show and a podcast
for those interested where he began a
meaningful collaboration with the host
and producer Ira glass who I'd love to
have on the podcast at some point.
Currently Mike is the creator,
writer and star of the new film,
don't think twice,
which is hilarious.
Heartrending
just a wonderful watch.
I saw an early preview copy and it
blew me away, so I highly recommended.
I don't say that lightly.
It's a great movie.
If you've struggled with notions
of feeling like a failure,
hoping for success,
achieving some degree of success,
and then getting more or less
than you bargained for, it's,
it's an incredible journey.
So I do recommend you check that out and
had hell does he pull all of this stuff
off? He seems to be juggling
a million projects. I am to
find out. We dig into it.
So without further ado,
please enjoy Mike Birbiglia.
Mike, Welcome to the show. Thanks. Damn.
It's a very exciting and timely
for me to be here and uh,
because I, because I'm, I'm, I'm,
I'm digging into all of your stuff.
I'm immersing myself in.
It is affecting my life in real time.
So speaking with you is almost a
virtual reality experience. Well,
I think this is a mutual feeling since
I've been a consumer and fan of your
comedy for so long and I've
started thinking after Elon
Musk hints that we could
be logically speaking players in
some sophisticated future entities,
video game, uh, that, um, this
might all be a virtual reality.
I'll be at a very sophisticated one.
But if I want it to bring
us back to the earth,
at least as we understand it for a second,
I painted a number of mutual friends
of ours, Brian Koppelman of course,
fame, screenwriter, all around.
Good guy. Uh, Chris Saka,
both of whom had been on
the podcast before because
they've spent some time with
you.
And I wanted to ask a number
of things that they brought up.
So the first was from compliment
and I asked very specifically,
does he have any obsessions that you know
of outside of comedy and one word back
pizza. That's correct. So can
you elaborate on this please?
If that's an embarrassing,
uh, session is, it's simple,
you know, it's, it's, it's bread and
cheese and sauce. I mean, if that,
hearing you say that makes me realize
how simple of a human being I am.
I have a joke for my first album to drink
Mike, which is, I love pizza so much.
I would marry,
it would,
it would just be an elaborate ploy to
eat her whole family at the reception,
but it's a [inaudible]. So seven,
so stupid. Yeah. I love pizza.
I think it's just, you know, it's the
simplicity of it. It's from my childhood.
It's, Eh, there's no deeper
meaning other than my,
by the time my mom raised me,
um,
that's,
that's Friday and saying that because
I was raised by my mother and father,
but my mother was around more often.
Um,
she really kind of gave up on
parenting and ordered pizza a lot.
Yeah. You know, like she
didn't want to cook that much
then, so she'd just be like,
let's just order pizza. So just got
very used to it and now I figure,
well, in my adulthood I might as well
be a connoisseur and have good pizza.
So what now qualifies
for you is good pizza.
If you could have one type
of pizza delivered to you.
And I'm sure there are many options,
but a is, are you a deep dish?
Are you a New York style thin crust?
What are we talking? Yeah. Yeah,
I think there's two kinds of pizza
that I liked most. One is New York,
New York, uh, thin crust,
uh, coal oven, and um,
places like Arturo's and
Lucali. Uh, Lewd. So,
and then I have this odd, you know, from
my childhood, just in Massachusetts,
there's a ton of Greek people.